Warren Buffett formula for Success one
good decision every five years what what
a what a great way to manage decision
making process right this is a guy
that's been added with his company for
58 years and he credits roughly 12
decisions so here we go Warren Buffett's
annual Reddit letter to shareholders
reflects that in the last 58 years of
investing and identifies only a dozen
good decisions they've made averaging
one every five years as a source of
Berkshire Hathaways three million seven
hundred and eighty four thousand four
hundred and sixty four percent return
over that period Buffett believes that
fewer than 20 decisions made a
difference for him and it's not about
getting every decision right but getting
the important decisions phenomenally
right his successful investment strategy
involved investing in insensibly priced
opportunities at big companies with
honest people competitive advantage and
understandable enduring and
mouth-watering economics and partnering
with the right people such as Charlie
Munger and Ajit Jane Tom what do you
have to say about this well I think if
you look back at it
um this kind of goes to uh and and folks
could Google this and the S P 500 the
longer you look at it the harder it is
to be right you've been in financial
services for a long time the longer you
look at it like five years ten years 15
years you make a little chart sure the
harder the s p is to be and if you look
deeper into that you can find these
stories that tell you that there were 30
days in the history of the s p that if
you miss those 30 days
um you you really miss something like
the 2009 had two days where there was
like these five percent bounce
turnarounds remember that yep you know
2009 everybody said what's going to
happen 2009 I'll send boing up five five
percent one day another five percent one
day and all of a sudden you're 10 for
the year and so what what uh Warren
Buffett is coming back and basically
saying is hey
um we've made 12 good decisions and we
could probably uh you're saying the
elementary what I just found according
to Hartford fund if you miss the
Market's 10 best days
over the last 30 years this is S P 500
your returns would be cut in half there
it is that's it and that's why the S P
500 Index like a cash index held for a
long time is usually a good idea and
that's why a lot of the life insurance
products like PHP sold you built this
monstrous Life Insurance Agency on a
nationwide basis Pat and a lot of those
iul index Universal lives were tied to s
p indexes so it showed that something
that's stable like life insurance so
back to Buffett you asked me about
Buffett I think if we decode this we're
going to find Buffett is saying like the
day I invested it the day I went all in
on coke the day Coca-Cola the day I went
all in on Geico I'd be willing to bet
that his 12 big decisions is probably
those days because remember there were
days where Buffett decided to go all in
on some companies that have come back
for him in spectacular fashion so it
sounds to me like he's saying the same
thing like the story you just just read
and what the common knowledge among the
investment Community has been about
long-term Buy and Hold on the S P 500
don't miss those days and by the way Tom
if if there are certain decisions like
when you think about creating wealth
right
um too many people put this pressure on
themselves I believe of getting it right
every single time right it's a different
story with Investments and and you know
things you invest into specifically than
it is with you know other things you do
in your life with Investments if you get
one thing right you know that could make
you a household name you could have
failed in 18 different businesses none
of them worked out and then all of a
sudden boom one thing you get right you
sell it for 50 million you sell it for a
couple hundred million you sell it four
billion dollars now everybody goes back
and talks about that one success story
right so it it Buffett's story validates
and hopefully encourages a lot of people
to be a little bit more patient he's
selling long-term thinking
with how to make your investment
decision I think it's a great a great uh
philosophy especially to learn from a
guy like him I heard a statement and
it's really short and it's this if
you're going to invest remember it's a
cornfield not a sports book you go in a
sports book oh maybe I'll bet on this
Laker game yeah and then 10 minutes 20
minutes later there's another game
starting maybe I'll bet on this one so
if you're bouncing in and out if you get
a Robin Hood account you're bouncing in
and out that's a recipe for you know you
never beat the sports book you may get a
one big hit once in a while maybe the
super professional gamblers get it but
the average guy going into a sports book
around the Super Bowl or March Madness
they never get it we see that whereas
you treat it like a cornfield what do
you do once a year you harvest some corn
and you have patience in between
agree so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
[Music]